well this morning in his first public
statement on the queen's death we heard
from prince harry and he called his
grandmother a guiding compass for the
nation he also thanked her for her sound
advice in his words well over the
weekend harry his brother prince william
and their wives greeted well-wishers
outside windsor castle it was a big
surprise it was the front page of all
the papers here and of course that's
where the queen lived most of her life
and holly williams is there at windsor
castle with more on harry's comments
this morning holly good morning
good morning nora well harry's statement
appeared on his website just this
morning with a photo of the duke
together with the late queen he referred
to her simply as granny and said he was
grateful for memories including the
first time the queen met his quote
darling wife and met her
great-grandchildren well this comes as
harry and megan's relationship with the
rest of the royal family appears as
complicated as it's ever been
nobody expected this estranged brothers
and their wives together again harry and
megan back on royal duty
more than two years after they quit i
think there are some major unresolved
issues at foot
roya knickers a royal correspondent
reporting on the monarchy for over a
decade for william and harry to agree to
come together and do that walk about was
not plain sailing what were they
disagreeing about probably the nature of
how they were going to do it you know
how close they were going to be were
they going to come in the same car were
they not
all of those things are at play
as the queen's health failed close
family members flew together to her
castle in scotland but harry traveled
alone and while representatives
initially said megan would accompany him
in the end she didn't go reportedly
because the royal family told the couple
they wanted to limit numbers kate also
stayed at home
in his first address to the nation as
monarch king charles seemed to offer an
olive branch i want also to express
my love for harry and megan
as they continue to build their lives
overseas
but he also highlighted the brothers
divergent paths promoting william and
kate to the roles of prince and princess
of wales that's the title last used by
diana had harry and megan not step back
from royal duties when they did they
would have stepped up too in terms of
positioning role seniority he is still
the son of the king but he's hanging out
with movie stars and making netflix
shows in america
there is a report in the british media
that william and harry could walk side
by side behind the queen's coffin at her
funeral however at this stage we cannot
confirm that nora
all right holly outside windsor castle
thank you so much